my name is tally Portnoy and my super
Europe project was lipid suppression
techniques for magnetic resonance
spectroscopic imaging in infants mrsi is
a technique that lets you view where
metabolites are present in tissues which
is important like various pathologies
can be diagnosed by measuring metabolite
concentrations right now when you try to
image the brain you only image and
inscribe rectangle inside the brain to
avoid exciting the lipid layer which
surrounds the head because if you excite
the lipid layer the lipid signal will
completely swallow certain metabolites
signals so the first step of my project
was to see if this is a problem in
infants because they have less fat
around their heads than adults so I did
two different scans or someone in my lab
helped me do two different scans one
with an inscribed rectangle following
the normal protocol and one with a full
rectangle to image the entire brain and
we saw that there was lipid signal
contamination so you see here the red
line is from full excitation skin and
the black line is from an inscribed
rectangle skin and for the full scan the
red completely swallow so you wouldn't
be able to see the black peak which
corresponds to a metabolite NAA so the
goal of my project is to reduce this
lipid signal so that you can measure
metabolites that are in the same
frequency range as them and I do this
using by solving an optimization problem